ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre naître ou ne
plus naître à hautain tel est désormais
la question question qui angoisse les
62000 habitants du Morvan entre
Saône-et-Loire Nièvre et Côte-d'Or Suite
à votre annonce de la fermeture de la
maternité d'Autun cette fermeture
provoque un vent de colère et de révolte
chez les équipes de soignants au combien
dévoués mais aussi chez les élus locaux
et la population devant ce qui est vécu
comme un nouveau déménagement du
territoire cette fermeture suscite
l'inquiétude des femmes enceintes
désormais contraintes de parcourir plus
d'une heure voire 1h30 de route pour se
rapprocher d'une maternité alors même
qu'une étude réalisée dans notre région
montrait combien l'augmentation de cette
distance retentit sur la santé
périnatale cette fermeture locale doit
préoccuper au niveau national car
monsieur le ministre vous avez commencé
par la justifier ainsi nous n'arrivons
plus à trouver des professionnels pour
assurer la sécurité est-ce donc là votre
seule politique après avoir fermé une
maternité sur trois en 20 ans votre
ministère va-t-il amplifier cette
concentration et fermer toutes les
maternités de niveau 1 du pays et puis
face au tollé provoqué par votre annonce
vous avez renié le mot de fermeture dans
un tweet qui disait inexact les
accouchements sont suspendus aujourd'hui
pour manque de personnel finalement
monsieur le ministre de la Santé est-ce
là votre seul ambition face aux pénuries
médicales que de demander aux femmes de
suspendre les accouchements et aux
malades de suspendre leur maladie
pour vous répondre la parole commise de
la santé Monsieur François Brown
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
Jeunet merci de me donner l'occasion de
parler de ce dossier dans le fond et
j'en suis sûr en dehors de toute
polémique
quelle est la situation actuelle les
accouchements sont suspendus à la
maternité d'otin depuis mi-décembre par
faute de personnel médical j'imagine que
comme moi vous refusez de mettre en
danger la santé des femmes par turiante
et des enfants parce qu'elle n'auraient
pas de personnel compétent pour les
prendre en charge alors des décisions
nombreuses ont été prises la première
j'ai décidé de repousser la date de la
commission qui devait dans quelques
jours décider de l'avenir du site pour
que nous prenions un peu plus de temps
pour construire des solutions pour
répondre aux besoins de santé de la
population il est hors de question bien
entendu que les femmes du Morvan n'est
pas de solution satisfaisante au moment
de leur grossesse
pendant ce temps nous allons continuer à
travailler avec les élus avec les
professionnels avec les représentants
des patientes et des patients plusieurs
pistes se dessinent déjà
particulièrement sérieuses la première
met en place sur hautain une ligne
d'intervention supplémentaire avec une
ambulance dédiée et une sage-femme en
complément du SMUR pour la prise en
charge éventuelle d'accouchement qui se
ferait en extra hospitalier ensuite nous
mettons en place un service de
périmaternité à hautain c'est à dire la
prise en charge des femmes jusqu'à
l'accouchement et tout de suite après
l'accouchement avec une antenne
d'ailleurs à Château-Chinon pour mieux
couvrir l'ensemble du Morvan de la même
façon mise en place d'un système
d'hébergement des femmes juste avant
l'accouchement sur nos principes d'hôtel
hospitaliers au plus près du plateau
technique d'accouchement et enfin la
mise en place de consultation de
pédiatrie sur le site en concertation et
en complémentarité avec le CHU de Dijon
et château
Chalon-sur-Saône pardon donc voilà les
solutions que nous travaillons j'aurai
l'occasion de venir sur place pour
présenter les solutions que nous aurons
définies ensemble bien entendu nous
mettrons le financement adéquat pour les
développer je suis de très près ce sujet
car il est emblématique de la
construction d'une réponse à l'échelle
du territoire et non plus simplement de
façon focalisée je vous remercie
monsieur je n'ai
que le ministre j'entends votre
proposer effectivement la transformation
de la maternité en centre périnatal de
proximité comme un une très grande
nouveauté alors même que je crois que
les décrets de 1998 il y a 25 ans
prévoyait déjà cette solution et que
dans notre région ça a été tenté à
Cosne-sur-Loire et vous savez que ce
centre a dû fermer faute de personnel je
crois que les acteurs locaux attendent
des garanties réelles pour que votre
beau concept de maternité territoriale
ne soit pas seulement un slogan pour
masquer la réalité celle d'un territoire
sans maternité
merci